Mình sẽ hôm nay một hôm nay mình tìm tầy lớn nhất thế giới gửi hai người dễn ra tại cho hàng nè sữa vận Nam Phi đã khách lại với một tuyên bổ chung.
Cái khoảng này rất bất ngờ bởi trước đó, nhưng người lo, hôm nay sẽ không đạt được bất cứ thật nào.
Mời nên tìm tầy lớn nhất thế giới là Mỹ đã không cửa đại dễ gõ mặt.
Đông thời tiên bố tầy trang sự két và phản đối mọi người dùng bà két.
Nam Phi cũng ra giữ trước chủ, phải gửi hai người năm nay đã thích phụ gập mới tạm trên hai người thành viên kỳ vào trong những bổ chung chi trừ á hành tìm nào vào Mỹ.
Lấy giấu tháng lợi hiếm hoa ai của chúng nhẹ đà phương trước sự app hề quan của Mỹ,
vẫn bạn như các uống tiền như uống phó biến đổi khi hậu giảm lợi cho các nước nhau và thu hẹp khoảng cách giấu nhau.
Dạ, các cu差 và lần đầu tiên chúng địa sự gửi hai người còn đề xuất lập một nhau cũng tìa chuyên trách vẫn đề vẫn bình đồng.
Fiam Mỹ phải đứng mạnh, cáo buộc Nam Phi làm sai lịch và trọt chúng ta.
Qua xinh tơ cũng khẳng định tổng phần đối đông trâm sẽ đưa gửi hai người cho lạc đúng hình thịt được đăng cải sự sẻnh vào Nam Sau.
Trái lại tại hồi hì như nước bây tỏ uống hộ Nam Phi, đông thời cho rằng sự đoàn kết là này thì mong muốn duy trì gở hai người như một diễn đảnh thật tạc.
Một số đại điều nhìn rình, giữa các nước đoàn kết trước khả nấn trình Mỹ có thể tạo kiện lệ tốt, cho những năm tởi,
hương tời trường nhad đà phương thực chất trong khoảng hệ của tế.